les chiens guides d'aveuglés l'honneur
ce jeudi 28 mars le préfet des yvelines
est venu visiter pendant deux heures le
centre d'élevage et d'éducation jacques
bougnol installé depuis septembre 2015 à
buc
au programme découverte des boxes de
maternité pour les shows et
démonstrations avec les éducateurs
spécialisés
c'était important de montrer une
activité assez méconnu qui est essentiel
pour le bien-être d'un certain nombre de
malvoyants et aveugles et que qui a une
fonction sociale humaine extrêmement
intéressante positive
au total une quinzaine de chiens sont
formées en même temps sur ce site de
2000 mètres carrés ils sont pris en main
par 18 éducateurs des trois mois et demi
pour les rendre opérationnelles après au
minimum 18 mois de formation
ce sont des chiens qui vont avoir une
relation extraordinaire avec leurs
maîtres en eux en eux mêmes
est-ce qu'ils sont extraordinaires en
tout cas ils font tout ce qu'il faut
pour pour assumer la leur mission mais
ça c'est notre responsabilité de choisir
des chiens particulièrement équilibré
est particulièrement réactif à ce qu'on
leur demande
coût total pour la formation d'un chien
près de 25000 euros pour les aider les
lieutenants de louveterie des yvelines
leur ont remis un chèque de 500 euros
lors de cette journée